der weiße fleck auf der salami isst
schimmel genauso wie der auf dem
leberkäse diese fotos hat ein ehemaliger
mitarbeiter von weg gemacht und sie
haben auch gewerkschafter andreas
kampmann zerstört er wehrt sich gegen
die behauptung des landkreises die
mitarbeiter hätten sich nie beschwert
dass wo der geschäftsleitung gesagt auch
über die abteilungsleiter ebene dass es
hier mängel gegeben hat aber die wurden
einfach vom tisch gewischt so nach dem
motto macht du deine arbeit das andere
überlassen uns die wurstfabrik wurde vor
zehn tagen geschlossen der grund zu hohe
listerien werte listerien sind keime die
für immungeschwächte menschen
lebensgefährlich werden können gab es
schwachstellen bei den kontrollen fest
steht ende august wurde der weg betrieb
überprüft dabei wurden nicht zum ersten
mal massive hygienemängel festgestellt
kurz darauf stellte das landratsamt nach
einer weiteren kontrolle ein positives
zeugnis aus ein monat vor der
endgültigen schließung der fall zeigt
dass es eine viel zu große nähe gibt
zwischen denjenigen die einerseits
verantwortlich sind für die
gewerbesteuer die einzutreiben und
gleichzeitig dann aber auch die betriebe
in der region überwachen sollen
das darf nicht so weitergehen auch die
hessische verbraucherschutzministerin
betont dass sie bisher keine
möglichkeiten habe betriebe zu
kontrollieren oder zu schließen
es ist nicht unsere aufgabe das liegt
allein in der kompetenz der
kreisveterinäre ich möchte gerne dass
wir konsequenzen aus diesem fall ziehen
und das heißt nicht nur umstrukturierung
sondern nach ansicht von foodwatch auch
mehr kontrolleure damit sich ein fall
wie wilke nicht wiederholt